from cuts to cutlery from hotels to
office complexes matéo ton has won
countless awards for his work but most
of his products do not bear his name
the south tyrolean architect likes to
remain anonymous take these mineral
water bottles for example thus this is
an example of no design nobody will ever
know that the bottles are by us the 61
year old Matteo toon works with his
young staff of 50 in the Italian city of
Milan he's been in the business for
three decades a recently published photo
book documents his work
it includes 20 tiny houses known as
wineries built for a vineyard on the
Moselle River made of locally mined
slate they were recently awarded the
German wine architecture prize the idea
was to use the smallest possible measure
smaller than the surrounding apple trees
for many tiny houses for example you see
here the interior is like a monk's cell
one good Mesa you can enjoy the wine eat
very well and then you sleep in this
tiny room tun has created some design
classics like these espresso cups or
this oil and vinegar said he designed in
1978 from Milan architect a thought a
sorts us in the 1980s he was co-founder
of the Design Group Memphis as a
reaction to the soulless modernist
doctrine of form and function matteo
tunas had his own studio since 1984 he
doesn't see himself as an artist or a
designer he wants to be called an
architect he doesn't think much of
personality cults ghastly terms star
designer or star architect today every
hairdresser is a star it's better to
focus on the little bit that you can do
of those mega bossman come
matéo tune starts every project with a
drawing his latest project is a basis
made of Murano glass he created this
knife for a German company with his
partner Antonio Rodriguez this shape is
a cat I'd yeah you cannot say this is
designed by somebody is designed by the
fingers is designed by the man who has
to come these days matteo tune focuses
mainly on large buildings the side hotel
in hamburg a collaboration with artist
robert wilson was named hotel of the
year in 2001 his vigil Lewis Mountain
Resort and South Tyrol has won several
awards - and says everything should be
cast in one mould that's why his team
designs everything from the walls to the
spa
they say that is all the solution to
understand the soul of a place means
that nature the microclimate the wind
what direction the rain comes from where
does the Sun rise where does it set an
architect has to understand all of that
and then the architecture creates itself
for example this commercial complex
built in 2009
it's Milan's first building with
air-conditioning run on geothermal
energy environmental issues are
important for Matteo Tony the lifecycle
of an object whether it's a glass bottle
or a house has been the main focus for
years and we're trying to push the
limits here it's not about green washing
but about our firm conviction of
sustainability it's an approach that
reflects the spirit of the times and
it's in demand worldwide Matteo tune
will soon be opening a studio in China
you